[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
on june 23rd 2022
amazon revealed an experimental alexa
feature that allows the ai assistant to
mimic the voices of the user's dead
relatives
the company demonstrated the feature at
its annual mars conference showing a
video in which a child is seen asking
alexa to read the wizard of oz and then
you hear a unique voice we later learn
as his deceased grandmother reading the
book to him with a natural warmth and
inflection
amazon said its a.i systems can learn to
imitate someone's voice from just a
single minute of recorded audio
in an age of abundant videos and voice
notes this means it's well within the
average consumer's reach to clone the
voices of deceased parents spouses or
friends
to create new messages
i can understand people wanting to
remember their loved ones pastor ross
but this could get a little creepy
because
i think people already think that the
dead are communicating with them that's
right pastor doug it's interesting you
know when you
get a phone call and you answer the
phone you could for the most part tell
who's calling you by the sound of their
voice especially somebody you know well
you don't have to ask or look at the
call id to see who this is we connect
the sound of a person's voice with who
they are their personality and you know
it's not a new thing but even the bible
speaks of people wanting to communicate
with a dead loved one now maybe they
want to see the person but for sure they
want to hear this dead loved one
communicate to them that's not only
something we find in the bible but i
think most of our listeners know that
there is just
an increased interest in communicating
with the dead yeah and the bible
forgives or forbids rather what it calls
necromancy or trying to a medium someone
who tries to communicate with the dead
and you can read in ecclesiastes chapter
9 verse 5 so the living know that
they'll die
but the dead do not know anything
and so
and you can read here there it is on the
screen for those watching the tv program
neither have they anymore a reward for
the memory of them is forgotten and
verse 6 goes on to say
for their love their hatred their envy
is now perished neither have they any
more apportioned forever in anything
that is done under the sun under the sun
meaning in this life
now where a lot of people get confused
we know that when a believer dies
their next conscious thought is the
resurrection and the presence of the
lord
but that doesn't happen until the coming
of the lord for them it's instant it
feels instant
but the dead haven't gone to heaven
until there's a resurrection the
judgment hasn't happened yet
and that's the future
so this idea that we can communicate
with the dead is a great fallacy and i'm
surprised how many christians believe
that they're getting messages
from the dead and this is spiritism
really
now somebody might be wondering well
what's the big deal so what if you think
your dead loved one is speaking to you
well we do know that the bible tells us
that at the end of time the devil is
going to do everything he can to deceive
and one of the deceptions of the devil
is going to be impersonating dead loved
ones to lead people astray the bible
says that the devil is able to perform
signs and wonders and especially at the
end of time there are these evil spirits
that are going around the world and
they're trying to deceive people so if a
dead loved one shows up and they're
communicating something and they say oh
this is you know a message from heaven
and if a person doesn't understand what
happens when a person really dies well
they setting themselves up for deception
yeah and especially something that's
going to contradict what you find in the
bible
it's dangerous and this has happened
before as well
well now some of our friends might want
to know where are the bible verses what
does it say about this subject of
are the dead really dead and you'll be
happy to know friends that we do have a
free offer that gives you a whole study
on what the bible teaches on this the
study guide is simply entitled are the
dead really dead and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number to call you'll see it on your
screen if you're watching is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide by
name are the dead really dead or ask for
offer number 117
and we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone in north america i know we do
have folks who are listening outside of
north america and if you'd like to read
the study guide we encourage you to go
to the amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.org you'll be able to read
it there you can actually sign up for a
free bible study you can do this both
online or you can actually mail in your
study guides and you'll go through a
series of great bible lessons helping to
understand these important truths of
scripture you know pastor we also want
to welcome those who are joining on not
only listening on satellite radio and on
land-based radio stations but we are
folks who are also watching at the
amazing facts television station or
channel as well as watching online on
the doug batchelor facebook page on the
amazing facts facebook page so we want
to greet all of you if you have a bible
question our phone lines are open and
the number to call is
800-463-7297 again that's 800-463-7297
if you pick up your phone and
give us a call there's a very good
chance that you'll get on tonight's
program but before we get to the phone
lines we always like to begin with
prayer so let's do that now dear father
in heaven we thank you for your word we
thank you for the opportunity we have to
be able to study together we ask your
blessing upon those who are listening
wherever they might be and be with us
here in the studio as we open up your
word and we ask this in jesus name amen
amen
well we're ready to go to our first
phone uh first caller pastor that we've
got anthony listening in new york
anthony welcome to the program hello uh
good evening pastors evening
uh matthew chapter um
uh believes matthew chapter 27 verse 53
it says um
uh verse 52 this has to do with the
resurrection
of the christ and it says and the graves
were opened and many bodies of the
saints which slept arose
in verse 53 says and came out of the
graves after his resurrection and went
into the holy city and appeared unto
many
my question is actually related to
revelation chapter 14 where it talks
about the 144 000
so as i read verses one through four
it seems to allude to
the hundred and forty four thousand
being a number from the past especially
when it says that uh it's the first
fruits
of christ
could the
saints that were raised at the
crucifixion and resurrection of at the
resurrection of christ
be part of or be that 144 000 or are we
only looking towards the future
well i think that i think the whole key
to understanding the hundred and forty
four thousand and i'm more convinced of
that today than i was yesterday because
i read about it again this morning
is that
the number really denotes
a leadership
among god's people so first fruits
doesn't always mean sequential first
fruits can mean
from like the 12 apostles were a type of
first fruits for jesus
and you read in the old testament i just
got done reading where david had an army
of 288 000
that would rotate
and that's two times 144 000. i think
there were six months they each would be
kind of on duty and off duty so they
could take care of their homes and farms
so it's two sets of 144 000
and then you can read there was uh 288
people that ministered in the sanctuary
that's again they had by day by night
there's
12 hours in the day 12 in the night
that's 144 144 000
but they're leaders
this is his army it's his priesthood
and so i think the 144 000 when it says
first fruits is not talking about a
hundred and forty four thousand that
were resurrected at the crucifixion of
christ
i think it's still speaking at the time
it was written it's looking forward to a
group near the end of time
so i have a book we have a free book
we'll be happy to send you a copy where
it reviews that
and or anyone that wants to know it's
about 144 000. if you'd like to see the
book all you need to do is call our
resource phone line that's 800-835-6747
you can ask for the book called the 144
and we'll be happy to send it to whoever
calls you know pastor the actual title
of the book i'm looking for it here who
shall sing the song i believe it's
entitled talking about 144 000 and that
is free to anyone in north america again
just call 800-835-6747
we'll send that to you our next caller
that we have is wesley listening from
california wesley welcome to the program
yes thank you
my question is basically should we move
now to the country
so we can avoid
buying and selling and being stuck with
the
mark of the beast
all right well let's let's look at that
first let me read that for our friends
that are listening
says that part of the persecution of the
beasts in the last days it says that no
one might buy or sell except he who has
the mark or the number of the beast or
the number of his name
and it really shouldn't shock anybody
that one of the things the devil is
going to use in the last days is going
to be economic sanctions i mean
you can turn the page in the news right
now and it's talking about economic
sanctions that of governments against
russia and and other governments
if they're not complying with
international uh norms
um
we also saw just in canada there were
some protesters a trucker's protest
and uh anyone that was arrested i think
they had their bank accounts frozen
and that's kind of unnerving to think
that
everything is digital now and it's so
easy for the governments to monitor
a person's buying and selling
that i don't think anyone is shocked to
hear that the beast power in the last
days will use some sort of economic
sanctions on those that do not
worship appropriately now
because you may not be able to buy or
sell people are thinking well we don't
know when that is should i run to the
hill start planting a garden so that i
don't starve
i don't think i would react for that
reason
because
people who read these verses 50 years
ago or 100 years ago they could have
said we're going to run to the hills and
and grow our own food there's advantages
to country living but i would not move
to the country because of revelation 13.
i think when things get that bad
god has always fed his people
in those times of trouble
so are there good reasons to move the
country yes
should we do it because the days come in
when you can't buy or fail or buy or
sell
well i think there'd be advantages to
that but um i want to make that your
first consideration
so you know i've got a book on that and
it talks about uh heading to the hills
and some a beginner's guide to country
living so you could go to amazing facts
and i wrote a little book on country
living
and uh
great benefits but if everybody if all
the christians run to the hills right
now who's going to do evangelism
you know if i said i'm talking about uh
country living i think you also have a
video i was just watching it the other
day
of country living of course you've got a
place in the country and you spent
quite a while um cutting wood and
actually before you went into full-time
ministry and you were selling firewood
so you you spent a lot of time up in the
hills in the mountains on
uh quality you've been there it's pretty
far out it's pretty neat yeah that's how
far i mean it is way off the grid so
that is a great video i think it's
available on youtube yeah just go to the
bachelor country living i'm sure it'll
pop up yeah all right well thanks for
your call wesley we've got lonnie
listening in arizona lonnie welcome to
the program
everyone's always afraid of what's going
to happen at the judgment seat of christ
and
again if you've died in christ then you
know that your book in your name is in
the book of life and all of that and
that our sins are washed away you know
as of uh
isaiah 1 18.
but my question really is
do our dirty laundry and i've heard you
say this
during some of your sermons
that uh it's basically about rewards
which i know both of you are going to
embellish on and the thing is that
the good and the bad deeds
they're going to be aired but to whom
well
i think that if you have repented of and
confessed your sins there under the
blood of the lamb
and the lord will
protect us god is not wanting to out us
um
you know it was judas who finally turned
away from the lord
uh his sins of stealing and everything
were made manifest
but i think the lord is is looking to
protect and to wash away and treat his
innocent those that
repent of and confess and turn from
their sins he's not
they don't come before them into
judgment because jesus is really being
judged for those things
and you know there's two things been
blotted out of the books of record
if you're
a believer but you turn away from god
then your name gets blotted out of the
lands book of life but if you're a
believer and you remain faithful to god
then your sins get blotted out or at
least to the book of sin in heaven and
that's a good thing right so when we are
forgiven at the end of that judgment the
sins all cleansed the book so to speak
our cleanse the record of sin is removed
so that's good news no one's going to be
up there in heaven during the thousand
years you know thumbing through the book
and saying oh look what he did oh look
what she did no the sins of the
righteous they blotted out that's why
you you've got that robe of
righteousness it's a covenant right
absolutely very good thank you good
question
we've got uh caleb listening from new
york caleb welcome to the program
hello thank you pastor doug your pastor
pastor ross how you guys doing good
oh by the way pastor doug bash i love
your sermon on saturday on samson oh
praise the lord
okay i'm glad you enjoyed that
my question is for you for you is um
i'm going through
a lot of
problems right now like mentally and
stuff like that
i haven't been praying and
spending time with
on the bible and
am i like um
what what can i do to get back or am i
already doing
like or god's spirit has left me is that
why i'm not like
you know
don't well first of all don't
don't think that you're doomed you
probably wouldn't be calling if you were
doomed the holy spirit's still working
with you every believer has ups and
downs
you know life has ups and downs
the weather has ups and downs there are
days the sun is shining through and
there are days that clouds obscure the
sun the sun is still there
but the earth rotates and the sun is
hidden and the storms come and the sun
is hidden but the sun is still there god
he loves you and it's consistent
you can make a decision to love the lord
and say i'm committing myself to the
lord
that doesn't mean there aren't going to
be ups and downs when you get married
you make a covenant you make a
commitment they're going to be ups and
downs in your marriage but you're still
you've got that unconditional love and
that commitment and so yeah don't don't
be discouraged now you may need to
rediscover that first love
there may be things you need to do to
reignite your faith and faithfulness
spend time in prayer
repent of your sins or you know repent
and turn from your sins
ask the lord for his grace and as soon
as you do that he'll send the refreshing
of his spirit again
so
and every believer may have to do that a
thousand times or more in their
experience
that we often seem to sometimes go
through ups and downs their highs and
lows
that's just part of life it's also part
of the christian life do not think it
means that god has abandoned you
you know the bible tells us in second
corinthians chapter 506 that we walk by
faith not by sight yes so what that
means is you might not always feel a
certain way it doesn't mean god has
abandoned you but we walk by faith
trusting in his word even if we don't
necessarily feel any different or feel
differently we take god at his word
that's right okay next quarter that we
have is connor listening from colorado
connor welcome to the program
hello pastors how are you guys doing
good thanks for calling uh
thank you my question is kind of similar
to the last one
but um i was just wondering how a person
would know if they've committed the
unpardonable sin
all right first
when we hang up
request the free book we'll send you a
book on that we get this question a lot
and
you know
one of the most frightening things that
jesus said is that all manner of sin and
blasphemy can be forgiven but he that
sins against the holy spirit or
blasphemes the holy spirit cannot be
forgiven
and people go wow
there is an unforgivable sin i wonder if
i've committed that sin
and
99.99
of the people that worry about that have
not of course no one knows the heart but
god but
um
sometimes we're convicted by the holy
spirit to turn from our sins we think
well maybe i've gone too far the devil
often wants us to think we've gone too
far
there's a story in the book of zechariah
i believe it's chapter 3 where the high
priest is wearing filthy garments and
the devil is there accusing he's
basically saying you know he can't be
saved he's gone too far
when michael comes to resurrect moses
the devil is there saying oh moses
sinned you can't take him to heaven so
the devil is the accuser of the brethren
he often wants us to think we've gone
too far
if we're willing to repent and turn to
god god is willing to forgive
grieving away the holy spirit is not
something that happens
through usually one particular sin but
it's a process of years of rejection
of god's spirit so that the volume of
the holy spirit goes down where we just
don't even hear it anymore
examples of those who committed the
unpardonable sin in the bible would be
balaam
king saul judas
i mean they just they you know judas
what he called the saul went to a witch
and god stopped speaking to him but it
was 40 years of rebellion that preceded
that
and it was three and a half years of
judas
sinning in the face of god's
own son teaching god is very patient so
don't be discouraged and do sin for that
free book about what is the unpardonable
sin
you know we also have a book passed
today the previous scholar we probably
should have mentioned it at that point
too it's called 12 steps to revival
you're talking about how do you rekindle
that that love for god that first faith
and we'll be happy to send it as well if
you'd like to receive either of these
books or both of them the number to call
is 800-835-6747
you can ask for the book what is the
unpardonable sin you can also ask for
the book 12 steps to revival and if
you're in north america we'll be happy
to send it to you
next caller that we have is andrew
listening in kansas andrew welcome to
the program
hi all right
hi doug hi ross how you guys doing good
thank you for calling
my question is uh god said there's only
one god and i i got brought this
question and i don't know how to answer
it and so
god the son is our god too so
they're trying to tell me that there's
two gods
yeah
i know people get that that's a common
it's a common and a normal uh
misunderstanding when it tells us in the
book of deuteronomy chapter six
hear o israel the lord our god is one
and the bible says several times there
is one god
in the hebrew mind the way they use the
word one is not always talking about
numerical
quantity it's talking about unity
jesus prayed to the father and he said
in john 17 father i pray that they
meaning the 12 apostles i pray they may
be one
well there's 12 of them but he wanted
them to be united he said father i pray
they may be one even as you and i are
one so jesus was not asking the twelve
apostles to merge into one person
he was asking for them to be of one
spirit to be united
as jesus and the father and the spirit
are united
and so
all of the pagan religions
many of them anyway they were
polytheistic they had many gods the god
of the bible it's a one united god
and so that god in the beginning god
says let us make man in our image it's
plural
so right from the beginning of the bible
we know that god is composed of a united
god
meaning one
in spirit in unity and purpose
and i know it's somewhat mysterious but
it's composed of three unique persons
god the father the son and the holy
spirit
and we have a book we can send you on
that that deals with uh one god or three
is the trinity biblical the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
book it's called one god or three
what does the bible teach about the
trinity of course the word trinity
pastor is not found in the bible but the
idea of
the three
members of the godhead the father son
and holy spirit that is very biblical
let me find that throughout scripture so
be sure to call and ask for that book
you will be blessed next quarter that we
have is linda listening in missouri
linda welcome to the program
praise god i dispersed before asking my
question i just wanted to let you know
that both you doug and jane that
because of you guys you're both going to
have an extra crown or extra star on
your crown because
you guys both led me to
to christ and
the fullness of everything and i just
wanted to thank you both on that
my question is about the amplified bible
and what do you think about it is for a
good main bible or a study bible
yeah
for our friends that are listening the
amplified bible is a bible that and
correct me if i'm wrong linda but i
think it's you're talking about the
bible that's got a verse but it'll have
like four translations of each verse and
something yeah it says um
for the behind the original greek and
hebrew
yeah well i guess there's a few
amplified bibles but the one i'm
thinking of
as it goes through the different verses
you'll see
each verse will have different
different versions of that verse so you
can amplify each verse a little more and
it shows you some yes some expound more
on the greek and the hebrew
but it's a great study bible so if you
want to dig deeper into each verse and
look at it through the eyes of different
translators to get little nuances most
of them say exactly the same thing
but you often get little nuances and
insights through different words it
expands your understanding nothing wrong
with looking at the amplified bible as a
study bible
well you know i think there's also an
amplified bible if you're not mistaken
which is a paraphrase
where they will take an english version
and they'll confer with the greek and
hebrew but they'll take
an english bible and they would they'll
write the verse using different words
and maybe expand on different ideas
so um there is a difference between an
actual translation and a paraphrase so
we just want to be aware of that
translation is a direct translation of
the original text sometimes the word
order is changed just a little but a
paraphrase is somebody adding uh some
flavor you might say or an angle or
perspective or putting it in different
language for people to understand
that definitely helps me so much thank
you very much and you too have a
wonderful evening
all right god bless thank you
next quarter that we have is pat
listening in colorado pat welcome to the
program
thank you very much
my question is
jesus is called the firstborn of god and
why is jesus called the firstborn of god
before he was born
human on earth
where are you talking about what verse
um i i didn't get the verse um written
down
it's always said jesus is the firstborn
of god and were adopted into the family
of god
right well jesus is the he's the only
begotten son he is called the firstborn
it's not because he was the first human
born
you know of course god made man in his
own image but the only time that god
became a human was in christ
and so you know he has preeminence
because of that the book of hebrews also
tells us
but again i don't think that it's
talking about
the firstborn as in sequence now when
you talk about
well let me back up and correct myself
in the hebrew the firstborn son had a
special inheritance right
and he was given special privileges in
that sense jesus spiritually is the
firstborn he receives those special
inheritance rights he is the greatest
among the sons so to speak
but
obviously jesus wasn't the first time
that a human was born
so i guess we got about 25 seconds till
the break pastor ross anything you want
to add to that yes i mean if there is a
phrase in the old testament that seems
to indicate or a reference to the
firstborn it's usually messianic and
it's pointing to jesus and the fact that
he would come and he would be considered
the firstborn in position and rank
because it's through him that anyone
else is saved yep all right friends
we're going to take a break we are
coming back in just a moment with more
bible questions but we have some
important messages
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
can't get enough amazing facts bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aftv.org
at aftv.org
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aftv.org
[Music]
what if you could know the future
what would you do
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a military prodigy
150 years in advance
cyrus had been named
rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
this intriguing documentary hosted by
pastor doug batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time
are you ready
have you ever skipped a meal not a bad
idea if you need to watch your waistline
but there's a heavenly food you should
never skip god's word yet how can you
dive in daily when you're so busy
amazing facts has you covered and it's
as easy as signing up for our daily
devotional and verse of the day both
sent directly to your inbox ready to
bless inspire and inform you to start
receiving the amazing facts daily
devotional and verse of the day visit
amazingfacts.org and click on bible
study in the main menu you'll be glad
you did
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 pm
and 8 pm pacific time to receive any of
the bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call 800 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
back listening friends to bible answers
live and if you've joined us somewhere
along the way we are a live
international interactive bible study we
invite you to call in with your bible
questions you can be listening on the
radio you could be listening on the
amazing facts facebook page the doug
batchelor facebook page af tv and other
stations my name is doug batchelor my
name is john ross and we have a number
of folks who are standing by on the
phone we're going to go to damon in
oklahoma city damon welcome to the
program
hello paris good evening evening
and your question
yes sir yes sir thank you um so i've
been trying to
um confirm the holy spirit in the guy
head a little bit more
and i've been reading some scriptures
i'm getting a little i get a little
confused
is the holy spirit
in the spirit of god
two different things or is it one in the
same
well i can't imagine a case where
someone would receive the spirit of god
without the holy spirit
so the the holy spirit is the one and
sometimes in king james it calls it the
holy ghost the same word
um
we don't today we think of ghost as a
you know spook or something but
um it's really the spirit of god and
when it says the spirit of the lord came
on samson or the spirit of the lord came
on david or they were baptized in the
holy spirit the bible says there's one
lord one faith one spirit
and so it would be the same
so like the when it says like the bread
like when it for instance when they say
god breathe the spirit which is like the
rock the
breath oh and now i see what i see what
you're talking about now that now that
is a little different
i you know when it's talking about um
the breath of life that is talking about
the air of life
and of course it's even there it's the
spirit of god that is infused in a
person but the word really is breath
like when you breathe
and when it tells us in genesis god
breathed into adam and that word in
hebrew is
in greek it's the word numa which is
where we get pneumatic tools tools that
run on air or pneumonia it's a it's a
sickness of the air or the breathing
um
so that was that's the word pneuma
that's talking about the wind or the air
and sometimes that's interchangeable
with the word spirit it depends on the
context you know there's different
symbols used for the holy spirit in the
bible you have wind as you mentioned
past today also fire is a symbol of the
holy spirit
at times and then also water can
symbolize the holy spirit so you've got
these different symbols that appear in
the bible but it's illustrating or
pointing forward to the holy spirit yeah
we've got a book we'd be happy to share
with damon that's dealing with the holy
spirit
and it talks about the need of the holy
spirit and this goes into some of the
definition definitions of the spirit
there we'll be happy to send you a free
copy damon the number to call is
800-835-6747 and again you can just ask
for the book it's called the holy spirit
the need and we'll be happy to send it
to you damon or anyone listening in
north america outside of north america
you can still read it but please go to
the website amazingfacts.org
we have jesus listening in florida jesus
welcome to the program
hello pastors thank you for taking my
answer my question
so my question comes from first
corinthians 7 12. i was doing a little
bit of study because i've been going
along with like the yearly bible study
plan that you guys have but i'm a little
delayed
and um
the question is pertaining to when it
says but to the rest i not the lord say
if any brother has a wife practically
paul saying
um
that he
not the lord is advising
i guess you could say like the
corinthian church i wanted to know what
are your guys's thoughts
yeah i think paul is taking a humble
approach here he's giving some counsel
to the church
he's also giving counsel to
a particular church
and he's saying look i'm not giving this
to you as a command from god but my
judgment and paul actually uses that
word other times this is in my judgment
and he's disqualified he said this is my
judgment now of course he is an apostle
inspired by god so his judgment
he probably underrated his own judgment
but
yeah he's talking about this situation
if if a man's got a woman she doesn't
believe and she's willing to stay with
her he's saying let her not divorce him
now this is actually a position of most
churches
that
believers should not divorce their
unbelieving spouses because marriage is
a sacred union
and
paul said who knows you might be able to
convert your unbelieving spouse peter
reinforces this when he says and i think
it's first peter chapter 3 where he says
that the unbelieving
husband can be converted by the chaste
behavior of the believing wife
and so it's a principle that i think is
a scriptural principle paul
he seems to
approach it with some humility saying
you know in my opinion
does that help
that's yeah definitely thank you yeah
and we by the way we do have a book on
marriage divorce and remarriage and we
we do address this issue in that book
the number to call again is 800
800-835-6747 that is the resource phone
line you can ask for the book called
marriage divorce and remarriage and
we'll send that to anyone who calls and
asks we've got matthew listening in
toronto matthew welcome to the
program i pass the time for taking my
call uh based on genesis one
the bible god made
male and female so my question is
is it okay for me to change
from male to female and god still love
me and can i be saving god's kingdom
well god
you know people often
do sinful things
and god is a god of love so the bible
says what can separate us from the love
of god god loves us
can a person continue in known sin
whatever that sin is
and still be saved no if we don't repent
of our sins we can't be saved
so now then the other question is is it
a sin for a person to try to change
themselves from male to female i believe
it is
i think the bible tells us that god
makes a person for one thing it's it's
biologically impossible
it doesn't matter how many procedures
and chemicals and hormones you receive
the differences between men and women go
all the way to the genetic level
and you are born either one or the other
i know there are some rare cases of
people that have some deformities when
they're born but
the very genes the the x and the y
chromosomes in male and female are
different that cannot be changed you
know i think there was just an
interesting ruling that was made
everyone was aware in the news how there
was a certain
male swimmer who went through you know
the outward
change to try to be transformed into a
female
and as a male swimmer he was a mediocre
but as a female swimmer suddenly he
began to just you know break all the
records and all the girls began to
protest well first they were afraid to
because it was politically incorrect and
they began to protest and said
there's just no way we can compete this
is not fair he is physiologically a male
the surgeries don't change things
and now the the sports board that
governs that department has agreed and
they said someone who has entered
a puberty as a male they cannot compete
as a female
of course i don't think they should ever
at any point but um so i i'm meandering
to answer your question
god made them male and female the lord
does not want a male should not dress
like a female the bible says that's in
deuteronomy i think it's 18.
a male should not dress art and maybe
it's deuteronomy 22.
a man should not put on a woman's
garment or a woman put on a man's
garment for all that do so are an
abomination unto the lord if god made
you a man celebrate how god made you or
if he made you a woman be thankful and
celebrate and live that out
that's god's plan
all right well thanks for your call
matthew next caller that we have is
steve in new york steve welcome to the
program
my question involves joshua chapter 6
and in joshua chapter 6 the lord
instructs joshua to take the men of war
and some priests to march around jericho
and they were to do that seven days so
my question is one of those seven days
would have been the sabbath and i'm just
wondering why
god would have instructed them to march
on the sabbath um
doing that or was it again maybe a maybe
not common but not unusual for
israel to go into battles
even when it was the sabbath day
yeah good question all right so in the
story of joshua it says you to march
around the city six times one
six days once
seventh day
seven times he's not talking about the
seventh day of the week he means the
seventh day of marching but your point
is still good that that would mean if
there's seven sequential days of
marching around jericho one of those
seven must have been the sabbath
um
well if god tells his army to go
march around a city and blow trumpets
that's really just a sabbath walk in
special music
there's nothing in there that's really
forbidden in itself they're not actually
going to war
but even
even among the israelites if they were
attacked by their enemies on the sabbath
day and that happens to modern israel
several of the wars have been launched
by
islamic enemies
on friday thinking that the jews would
be
the least
prepared
when pearl harbor happened it was not an
accident the japanese attacked pearl
harbor on a sunday morning
they knew it would be the day of rest
for the people in the city
and that they would be the least prone
to preparation for fighting
but the jews
as other armies they realize an army
needs to be equipped all the time and
prepared all the time and even the jews
had people who were a watchmen in the
temple on the sabbath
so
it's not a sin
for a jewish army or sabbath keepers to
defend themselves if they're attacked on
the sabbath day
there were some wars that the jews
fought that lasted for years
and obviously they didn't take every
saturday off
so
and when they're defending the cities
all right thank you um steve next
quarter that we have is jesse listening
in colorado jesse welcome to the program
hi
so my question deals with revelation 17
who is the lady and i have an opinion on
it already but i just want to hear what
you guys say
yeah revelation 17 is that chapter that
identifies this woman who's called
mystery babylon the great the mother of
harlots and abominations of the earth
says that she's got the many daughters
well i think the key to answer that
question this is a prophecy that was
written by john
uh john is a captive in rome when he
writes the prophecy and he says in verse
18 that's the last verse in chapter 17
the woman who you saw is that great city
that reigns over the kings of the earth
what city was reigning over the kings of
the earth when john wrote revelation
so i would say rome right correct
so a woman in prophecy is an allegory of
what
uh i have really no clue okay well the
bible says husbands love your wives as
christ loves the church and sometimes
god's church has been unfaithful so here
you have an unfaithful woman in rome
that becomes a very powerful
that gets involved in
intrigue and adultery with the kings of
the earth the only church that can fit
this description would be the roman
catholic church and by the way that's
not pastor doug or pastor ross this is
what was said by
martin luther
charles
spurgeon
john wesley
john calvin
uh all the protestant reformers
and many a matter of fact even
i think it was even pope gregory the
great who said any man that calls the
office
of the pope
to be you know the head of the church he
says he is antichrist
so um
yeah this was uh this is identifying uh
the roman catholic church says the woman
sits among seven hills roman's the city
of seven hills
so i think it's pretty clear
you know we got a study guide called the
other woman and it's talking about this
description we find in revelation
chapter 17. we'll be happy to send this
to you jesse or anyone wanting to learn
more about this very important chapter
that we find in the last book of the
bible you can just call and ask ask for
the study guide it's called the other
woman it's on revelation 17 the number
to call is 800-835-6747
and again as for the study guide called
the other woman
our next caller that we have is a keith
listening in
l.a louisiana keith welcome to the
program
can you explain um first peter chapter 3
verses 18 to 20.
it says for christ suffered once for
sins that just for the unjust that he
might bring us to god
being put to death in the flesh but made
alive by the spirit by whom talking
about by the spirit he also went and
preached to the spirits in prison who
formerly were disobedient when once the
divine longsuffering waited in the days
of noah while the ark was being prepared
it's talking about the divine
long-suffering it's talking about the
spirit peter is referring back to
genesis chapter 6 and i think it's verse
3 where god says my spirit will not
always strive with man but his days will
be 120 years
so it was the same spirit that rose
jesus from the dead
that spirit strove with unbelievers back
in the days of noah
and spoke to those who are imprisoned by
sin
it's not saying that when jesus died on
the cross that he went to a dungeon
somewhere to give special second chance
treatment to people that lived before
the flood
and this is you know what some people
have taught but
uh bible doesn't teach that is that kind
of what you were wondering
yes sir yes especially that part was a
bit um troubling
yeah um about
the spirits in prison so yeah that
doesn't make more sense the key to
understanding that as you go to genesis
chapter 6 verse 3 god said my spirit
will not always strive with man this was
written before the flood this is the
spirit the longsuffering of god for 120
years it says they would have from the
time that god called noah until the
flood came
and god spoke to the spirits in prison
by the devil meaning it's imprisoned by
sin
all right thanks for the call we've got
rhys now listening from north carolina
recently welcome to the program
hey thanks uh pastor doug pastor roth uh
i i got two questions first of all can
you read matthew 5 20 please all right
yeah you got it john you want to read
yes for i say unto you unless your
righteousness succeeds the righteousness
of the scribes and pharisees you will by
no means enter the kingdom of heaven
okay thanks now first question is simply
this if christ were here now dispensing
free education free medicine free food
he fed the crowd for free his charity
and generosity could you see him being
branded as a socialist that's the first
question
okay well
uh no you know of course
how would he be branded they everybody
branded jesus pretty poorly both the
legalists and the
the liberals the sadducees and the
pharisees didn't care much for jesus
jesus
freely dispensing he was not freely
dispensing from a government
he was personally freely dispensed and
he was encouraging believers to dispense
not compulsory
um
gifts and taxation in other words
america started out
where
the government depended on the goodness
and the christianity of people to care
for the poor
the hospitals the orphanages they
weren't run by the governments they were
run by the christians
but as time went by the government said
well we can't trust you to be good so
we're going to take the money from you
we'll run it
that's a whole different system than
what christ really was setting up well
you know pastor i'm thinking of another
verse it's clear the bible does talk
about our responsibility as believers to
help those in need yeah and that that is
the poor but on the other hand you do
find a principle that we read about in
2nd thessalonians chapter 3 this is not
the only place but the principle is
simply this
the one who does not work shall neither
eat in other words we need to work it's
not a good thing for us not to do what
we can to support ourselves and our
family
if we claim that we don't want to work
and we just want to get handouts well
we're lazy yeah contrary to what the
bible says so there is there is a
balance uh we need to be industrious we
need to do our best the bible says
whatever your hand finds to do do it
with all your might but there are people
that get sick there are people that
suffer need and as believers we want to
be aware of that and we want to help
people yeah so it's a different
structure that you see than what's been
promoted today in different political
circles so guys you had two parts to
your question what was the second part
okay the second question is simply this
the pharisees were more old-line stand
pat traditional strategy okay
that when saul
got his name changed to paul
did he leave the party of the pharisees
well he must have because i think paul
says i was a pharisee of the pharisees
and so he speaks of it in past tense
um of course i don't know if that's by
his choice or of the victim but he
considered himself a pharisee he had to
abandon some of the teachings of the
pharisees because the majority of the
pharisees rejected jesus
and of course the pharisees
fundamentally their theology was
righteous by works
and so paul you know becomes paul but he
was soul him being a pharisee of the
pharisees he was he was very
careful to observe every little
tradition that was created
trying to be righteous and then of
course he discovered the truth of the
gospel and realized righteousness comes
by faith in christ not as a result of
works right
all right well thank you for your call
we've got joseph listening in california
joseph welcome to the program
hello pastors how are you guys doing
doing great thank you for calling
you know first of all i want to thank
you guys for your ministry i've learned
a lot from listening to you guys
programs
my question is
what are your thoughts on home church
and does the bible say anything against
it
well
you see a lot of examples in the bible
of people meeting in homes in the early
days of the church if you look in the
book of acts
the you know of course christ first met
them in a home church in upper room
the last supper was in what you would
call a home church an upper room
the resurrection and the
early bible studies the holy spirit
being poured out this was all done in
homes they were not formally dedicated
church buildings with a more public
nature
and so
i personally think i know pastor ross
agrees that the strength of any church
is going to be not just what happens
once a week in the building
but in the homes
and in small groups
because that's where we really build
relationships and you can have more
intimate times of prayer
and know the people and know how to pray
for them
we learn how to get along and love each
other better it's sometimes easier in a
big church you can come in and go out
and not really get involved with people
but you don't always learn how to love
so
yeah i think that
i think the strength of even the modern
church is very important to be involved
in home groups
now i wouldn't abandon
the corporate getting together or maybe
a more
traditional facility
but
certainly nothing wrong biblically with
the home church
i think we even find in the bible for
example colossians chapter 4 verse 15
when christians were facing opposition
and persecution not only from
the religious leaders in jerusalem but
the romans as well they were groups that
met in homes and they were churches
colossians chapter 4 15 says greet the
brethren who are in laodicea and neifes
and the church that is in his house
so his house served as a gathering place
for believers and that was you might say
a home church but again that was a time
of persecution christianity was
spreading um
in a place of relative ease or peace
there's nothing wrong in building a
building dedicated just to the worship
of god where believers can gather
together and worship on a regular basis
you know i think one of the best verses
in that pastor ross is in acts chapter 2
verse 46
for continuing daily with one accord in
the temple that was the public place
and breaking bread from house to house
meaning getting together studying as
well as eating they ate their food with
gladness and simplicity of heart
praising god so
i think really a healthy church needs
both
absolutely
next quarter that we have is steve
listening canada steve welcome to the
program
good evening uh gentlemen thank you very
much for everything that you do like i
learned as well as many
people to try to work with the neuropath
with our savior
i was wondering the one-third of angels
who became demons and lucifer rebirth as
you explained by pastor
doug butcher had cosmic conflict in the
movie as well or they have this
mentality mindset that his weakness from
the two weakness where i understood that
he's jealous and proud do they have this
character and one and the following if
you don't mind just asking me
us when we are in christ we be coming in
the image of christ as our character but
once when we seen like judas
saw that you were quoted or they became
in the character of lucifer or satan the
devil
as they are also have the jealousy and
proud in them that is his character can
we inherit his image in his character of
satan violence just like we can get the
character of god okay
so when
when the angels that were deceived by
lucifer
when they fell and chose to follow
lucifer in his rebellion
they began to take on the
characteristics of lucifer which were
pride and selfishness and of course
the human race when we fell into sin
through our first parents our love
nature was damaged and we became very
selfish creatures so i think that i
don't pass ross it seemed to me that
everybody
that unless we're converted and born
again
people are motivated by selfishness and
pride
and we need to have our image
transformed
you know all things passed away all
things made new we're being conformed
into the image of his son
and so that is the plan of salvation you
know at the end of time pastor two
groups of people are described in the
book of revelation those are the mark of
the beast and those of the seal of god
those with the seal of god they reflect
the character of god those are the mark
of the beast they reflect the character
or the image of the beast meaning pride
selfishness so yes as we surrender to
the spirit of god as we seek god to
guide and work within us he creates
a new person by faith little by little
it's called sanctification
absolutely if we reject that though we
are setting ourselves up to reflect more
and more the devil
that's right you know we have a bible
lesson that talk well first of all our
caller asked about the cosmic conflict
dvd if you want to know more about this
rebellion where
uh
where did sin come from if god is more
powerful than the devil then if god is
good and if he's loving why doesn't he
destroy the devil did he make a devil
where why is there evil in the world if
god is good this is the big question a
lot of atheists ask they say i've got so
good if there's a god why is there
innocent people suffering
all of this is answered in that dvd
called cosmic conflict and you can order
that from amazing facts or you can
probably listen to it for free
everything seems to land on youtube if
you just go to youtube i'm quite certain
it's there type in cosmic conflict and
that'll really help you understand that
also there's a lesson you can get called
did god create a devil how do they get
that the number to call for that is
eight three five six seven four seven
and just simply ask for the study guide
it's called dead god create a devil and
pastor that we hear the music playing
the background but to those who
listening on satellite we're gonna be
signing off but for the rest of you stay
by we've got some great internet
questions that we're going to be
answering
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
hello friends welcome back this is our
final internet questions that have been
sent in past today we have about a
minute and a half to try and answer as
many of the questions as we can so we'll
get right to it here's the first one how
can i stay calm when somebody else
falsely accuses me
well it's not necessarily a sin to feel
some indignation when you're falsely
accused but i believe that the reason we
can find calmness is through the spirit
of god knowing jesus went through the
same thing look at christ at his trial
how calmly he bore
all of the false testimony that was
hurled at him
so
it's not unnatural to feel some
righteous indignation but then hopefully
you'll find peace knowing i can't change
that i can only change me
next question that we have why did jesus
cry out my god my god why have you
forsaken me on the cross when he knew
what was going on and what was to happen
well some people think that jesus
reached the point of despair when he
cried out my god my god why have you
forsaken me that's actually the first
verse in psalm 22
which was a messianic psalm which they
would normally quote from the messianic
psalms during the passover
christ hanging on the cross quoted from
the psalm that pointed to what he was
experiencing and in that very psalm it
says they've pierced my hands and my
feet
and people would see him saying that on
the
cross and they go
this is the prophecy that tells who he
is he was not uttering despair because
jesus did not ever lose faith
he was basically pointing us through the
fulfillment of that prophecy
okay another question that we have if i
don't know that i'm doing wrong will god
judge me for that
well the bible tells us in the book of
luke to him who knows his master's will
and does not do it he will be beaten
with many stripes he that did not know
and disobeyed is beaten with few you are
more accountable
for when you know god says my people are
destroyed for lack of knowledge because
they've rejected knowledge
and so um there is more accountability
when we know god's will
jesus said for he is someone who does
not know if if you did not know you
would have no sin but now that you say
you see your sin remains and that's the
gospel of john maybe time for one more
passage why didn't daniel go straight to
heaven okay meaning daniel the prophet
um believe it or not friends there is
more than one daniel in the bible
you know
it's really easier to ask
why didn't all the other good prophets
go right to heaven like elijah or enoch
ever all the other good prophets went to
their graves
god said daniel you will sleep until
that day
the last day of the judgment day hey
friends we are now out of time stay
tuned for some important messages we'll
study together next week
bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your bible questions